alors ce week-end dans les terriens du
dimanche à jean pierre pernaut du jt 13h
qui était l'invitée tir ardisson il a
été interviewé notamment sujet de
laurent ruquier pour la pour rappel
l'euro qu'elle avait qualifiée de
journalistes milite non regarde on avait
quand même d'un côté quand même aussi
des journalistes ray militants et
pourquoi pas parce que ça change de
d'habitude mais en même temps entre
voilà on a été militants qu'ils montrent
que quelqu'un comme jean pierre pernaut
qui est un journaliste militant qu'il
cache
oui alors et jean pierre pernaut lui a
répondu et jean pierre michaud ah oui
les chaudes la savate bien c'est un bon
humoriste
quand tu parles de chance sérieuse je
comprends moi mais est-ce que vous êtes
un journaliste militant non je raconte
la vie telle qu'elle est pas tel qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit fait la seule
différence avec d'autres ça quand on
regarde le compte facebook de quelqu'un
sur quelques années on peut tout mettre
d'un côté ou tout maître de l'autre
quand qu'a aussi dit quelque chose qui
me plaît je like je m'en fous de savoir
quel est ce site
contrairement à d'autres qui regardent
d'abord qui dit quoi pour savoir si
c'est bien ce que moi je m'en fous je
les emmerde que vous le disais tout à
l'heure
chérif alors voilà donc on est la
réponse de nokia pernaut gilles bien sûr
il a raison mais at il prend un tacle il
répond hors de son journal télévisé
c'est très bien dit et moi je trouve
aussi que je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec lui mais l'orque il ya des opinions
bobo c'est bien parfois je pense qu'ils
vont alors adieu moi ce qui m'agace
vraiment c'est que rooney m'ont paru
qu'il assume tout ouais c'est vrai parce
que jean pierre pernaut il n'avait pas
été bons chars des sons c'est que quand
il dit par exemple que les camps de
réfugiés il dit pendant ce temps là en
france des gens de mer paris des gens
meurent de faim fait consulting chez non
j'ai juste tire un constat ça
effectivement il prend une pénurie la
des opinions ils les expriment pendant
le jt de tf1 et après il a jamais des
couilles de dire oui ben je reconnais il
ya des moments où je donne mon avis se
dégonfle de cherbourg
oui non mais sans perdre qui se dégonfle
pas c'est vrai qu'au sexe il est connu
pour ça et l'accessoiriste toujours ses
lancements de jt par une petite remarque
un petit commentaire personnel
à partir du moment où il exprime ses
opinions personnelles dans un gîte et
qu'est censé parler à tous les français
moi ça ne suffit pas merci de pas me
dire son compte
après les avoir dit se rend compte qu'il
ya des files d amère je ne peux pas
contrarier cet accord